it was a dark phase I had been signed
for all these big movies and this thing
happens my face looks completely
different and I went into a deep deep
depression Priyanka Chopra reveals how a
botched procedure affected her Mental
Health
at that time I was 17 when I was thrown
into this pageant world I didn't seek it
it kind of happened to me I grew up so
quick the actress opens up on Sirius
xm's Howard Stern Show explaining how a
nose surgery she had in the early 2000s
went horribly wrong leading her to think
her acting career was over before it
started it was like the rug was pulled
from under me I was thrown out of three
movies and it was very embarrassing in
fact the Citadel star says her mental
health was so low she became reclusive
when movies came to me I was like oh
that should be easy but it's not it's a
job and then on top of that add the
public pressure always being under a
microscope at 18 it was just like it did
not prepare me that kind of Limelight
Priyanka previously shared details about
the botched nose surgery and her Memoir
unfinished writing that it left her
feeling devastated and hopeless it all
went down shortly after she was crowned
Miss World in 2000 when she developed a
lingering head cold and was having
trouble breathing Priyanka saw a doctor
who discovered a polyp in her nasal
cavity but she says the routine
procedure didn't go as planned according
to the actress while shaving off the
polyp the duck also accidentally shaved
the bridge of her nose and the bridge
collapsed
when it was time to remove the bandages
and the condition of my nose was
revealed mom and I were horrified my
original nose was gone my face looked
completely different I wasn't me anymore
Priyanka eventually had multiple
corrective surgeries to fix the damage
my father was a surgeon was like we've
got to do another surgery and I was
terrified of that and he was like I will
be in the room with you he held my hands
through it and helped me build back my
confidence Priyanka explains in her book
that she felt like a stranger when she
saw herself in the mirror but now she's
made peace with a slightly different
version of herself this is my face this
is my body I might be flawed but I am me
these days Priyanka who's married to
Nick Jonas is booked and busy I saw Nick
walking by looking Dapper of course he
got the memo too he got the memo has he
seen the show yet yes he's seen multiple
versions of it
um but sweetly he's gonna watch it again
not only is she a new mom to their
daughter multi you had both of your
girls getting ready at the same time we
have a little multi and free she's doing
last looks final touches of my time and
the little one approved it looks of
course right very much does she likes
everything shiny but she's also all over
our screens kicking butt on her new
Prime video series Citadel this show has
been five years in the making and we've
shot it over a year and a half it's it
was a lot and then our seed come
together and this amazing experience
it's really special and enchanting us
her new rom-com love again where she
Stars opposite her real-life leading man
this is my knight in shining armor I was
supposed to do this scene where the
actor like licks my face in slow motion
oh God exactly
[Laughter]
[Music]